all right thank you mike trudell please
hey lebron just study in the heat and
what you've seen from them in this
postseason
what's at the top of the list what
stands out the most to you about the way
that they're playing basketball
um i would think uh two things one how
hard they play
48 minutes no matter if they up no
matter if they're down
um they play extremely hard um
and i think uh two um it would be uh
the way they they move it on the ball
they share the ball um
everyone is live on the floor it's not
one guy that you can
disrespect or be off throughout the
course of offensive possession
um and they do a hell of a job of moving
without the ball
sharing the ball and passing um so
those are two things that stand out
lebron you've described that time in
miami
like it was going to college for you um
if you can think back to those four
years what were the most important
lessons that you learned about yourself
and about leadership in general um
i think as far as leadership you know
that grows
um no matter where you are every day if
you want to be a leader
if you strive to be a leader every day
um
i think being around um you know riles
and spo
d wade and ud and uh and
and you know just to name a few uh being
a part of that culture
um allow me to to grow um allow me to
see
uh you know what it takes to not only
compete for a championship but also to
win a championship
um you know so it definitely um
you know put me in a position where i
knew
what it took um i saw what it took
um but also um you know i fit that
culture as well because how hard i
worked
um so it was a it was a perfect match
for those four years
hey lebron uh it's bill auram would
would it have any extra meaning to you
to win a championship against
uh against pat riley and eric spoelstra
guys that have helped
shape you and vice versa um in those
years together
absolutely not it's too it's
it's no extra uh meaning to win a
championship no matter who you're
playing again it's already hard enough
to even reach the finals
to be in this position so if you're able
to become
victorious out of the finals it doesn't
matter who it's against
um you know you're just i'm just happy
that i'm here
with opportunity um you know to
represent
uh not only myself but represent our our
fans our our
fan base our organization uh my
teammates our coaching staff
um our training staff and so many others
that represent this organization
uh to the
lebron six years after playing for miami
how do you feel about pat riley
that's such a broad question dave i
don't understand
leaves it open for interpretation like
what how do you when you hear the name
pat riley what do you think about uh
how do you describe your relationship
with raleigh you think about uh
probably one of the greatest minds that
ever this game has ever had he's won at
every level seen a stat the other day
that he's been
part of a championship in four decades
um
this uh this league um
is not the same without without rouse
so um you know he's a great guy
a great motivator but someone that just
knows what it takes to win
and he's shown that over the course of
uh over the course of what 40 years
um lebron uh you talked about just sort
of the difficulty of adapting to
to the bubble um how much
uh have you sort of motivated yourself
by reflecting that you know your
teammates are taking cues from you and
trying to
see you know how you approach things and
and
sort of approach kind of getting through
this grind of three months here
um it's probably the most challenging
thing i've ever done
as far as a professional as far as
committing to something
and actually uh you know making it
through
um but uh
i knew that i was coming what we were
coming here for um
obviously you didn't i was i would be
lying if i sat up here that knew that
everything inside the bubble with what
it was you know the total that would
take
on your mind and your body and you know
and everything else
because it's been it's been extremely
tough
um but you know i'm here for
one reason and one reason only and
that's to compete for a championship
and that was my mindset once i aired the
bubble once i entered
uh the quarantine process the first uh
two days
um and then right from my first practice
my mindset
was to if i'm gonna be here um make the
most of it
um and see what you can do and lock in
on
what the main thing is and the main
thing was for us to finish the season
and compete for a championship so that's
just been my mindset
um you know throughout these i don't
even know how many days it is
whatever how many days it is it feels
like five years so
it really doesn't matter but i've been
as locked in
as i've ever been in my career dan
i won't remind you how many days it is
um
back in march the season comes to an end
two players on your team test positive
for this virus
did you know or when did you think
getting to this point was even a
possibility
and what was it like kind of mourning
the fact that maybe it wouldn't happen
um i didn't know that this was a
possibility until we actually got on the
plane
in l.a to fly here to orlando
um you know we have seen some of the
teams arrive
before us we had got here july 9th we
have seen some of the teams arrive a
couple days before us
but until we landed here and got off the
plane got on the bus
and actually pulled up um to the hotel
that's when it become
that's when it became a reality to me
all right
lebron from your vantage point what do
you think it is
about eric spoelstra that allows him no
matter if it's coaching
number one picks or kind of a collection
of undrafted
lower drafted guys that allows him to
continue to bring groups back here to
the finals
but also not necessarily always be in
the conversation with that
upper echelon of coaches um well that's
a question for you guys
and the players and the coaches know how
great spo
is and there's this narrative that spo
is not great
and um the narrative that he doesn't get
a lot of respect which he should
he prepares this team every single night
if you just watch the miami heat no
matter who's on the floor they're going
to play heat culture they're going to
play hard they're going to play together
that's what he's always been about and
um
it's been you guys that have changed the
narrative or or
has never given exposed respect because
he had d wade or he had myself you have
bosch
but a lot of coaches have talent a lot
of coaches have had talent over the nba
over the course of this league
that's not one um you know and
it's unfortunate that he hasn't gotten
his respect and every time we talk about
spo when i was there and talk about how
great he prepared us and we all talked
about it's great playing for small and
things of that nature
you guys always said well you know you
got you have lebron
you have d wade you have bosch any coach
can do it
not no any coach can do it if any coach
could do it then there would be a
there'd be a lot more champions in this
league there'd be a lot more successful
coaches
so spo likes that
that's what that's what that's what fuel
spoke is the disrespect that you guys
give them the the the basketball world
um and i'm not going to sit up here and
uh act like i don't know
what suppose all about because he's damn
good if not great
probably is great because his pep is
preparation
he prepares like this is his last time
ever coaching again every game
and i know that
that's why i feel good
lebron there is uh political financial
data that is out there that shows that
pro sports owners including mba owners
donate
overwhelmingly to republican causes um
i know they've pledged a lot of money to
help with racial and social justice
issues
but you feel that those political
contributions undercut
some of the efforts that players are
making uh to
gain progress in the on those topics um
well one i'm not going to give my
energy to that because it's not
surprising
um and
you can my mom has always told me that
you control what you control
and i can't control that what i can't
control is what i'm doing on my side
and trying to have people gather around
me and gather around my initiatives and
doing what we're doing
to try to affect change not only in our
communities but outside of our
communities
to the youth and understand let them
understand how important their voices
and their vote is um to our society and
it's hard as hell
because they just don't believe it they
don't believe that their
their vote or their message or their
minds or their voices
matter but that's what my energy is
on continuing to to push the envelope in
my community continue to
you know to let them know that they are
the future they are
the reason why there will be change but
i can't give my energy to
the other side because that would take
away from
for my people and and i can't do that
but
control what you control i can't control
that that is what it is and it's not a
surprise
um but i got work to do on the other
side so that's what my mission is about
let's take the last few questions go
chris
bro you mentioned you're as determined
as ever right now as locked in as ever
as you've ever been
and while usually during this
post-season run
you black out from social media you
don't do it but obviously you couldn't
do it this year in the bubble
away from family important election
coming up
how was that adjustment been for you
during this time to
have you know access to social media you
know can usually try to eliminate
distractions but
you got it right there handy yeah um i
think in this particular case
everything about this year is different
everything about 2020 is different
and uh to make the most of it you have
to be able to adjust
and um i've adjusted in the sense of um
understanding that there's also a
a bigger opportunity coming up as well
in november
while i'm still you know keeping the
main thing the main thing and to focus
on you know leaving a legacy here and
playing a game that i love to play and
compete for a championship
but also um letting my people know that
i'm not um
i'm not jaded and i'm not too distracted
rock cannot
um continue to um give the resources
uh put the people in place to um
help them go to the places where they
don't believe they can even go so that's
just um
sometimes i mean sometimes you do things
that even you personally don't even
believe that you can do
um but when you have a support system
you have a group around you that's just
as motivated as you you're able to um
you're able to tackle um a few things at
once
yes i will take the last two let's go
with brian
hey lebron i kind of wanted to ask you
that similar question so just to switch
back to basketball now since you
answered it um
you know the last couple times you were
here you were pretty outmanned by
a team with four great players uh as you
come back now with the team you have
around you how do you feel
going into this tenth finals now with
the you know you feel like talent wise
you know you don't have to worry about
that problem this time
um i never had a problem with any team i
went to the finals i've always been
confident
that we had the ability to win and um
if you're going to a final stand that
you're under man or you feel like you
don't have enough
then then who are you um you know and it
takes
the game is one in between the four
lines not one on paper
um and at the end of the day when i've
lost in the finals the better team won
because they played well they were more
prepared
and they did what it needed to do to to
win those four games
uh when i've won the same thing
so i'm not here to talk about the talent
that i have
you know the team that we have the game
is one in between the four lines
um 94 feet and the team that
is prepared and the team that execute
the team that has
um you know not not careless
um you know throughout 48 minutes will
give themselves a chance to win
um each and every game so i'm confident
going into
uh this finals as i've always been in my
career
all right last question joe varden
hey man um it's been a long time
obviously since you played for the heat
and a lot has happened
um to you and into the league since then
but
all these years later is there something
that you still take
away from your days in miami and then
the other one is
how are you different just from the last
time that you were in the finals
which was two years um
i think every part of anybody's
individual life
they was able to grow it never leaves
you
and that's no different from me having
my four years in miami
being around um you know with that
culture
growing um you guys don't realize you
don't talk about it but
i went to miami when i was 25 years old
i was 25
you know and i spent about 25 to 29
so i was still growing i was still a kid
and still trying to figure out who i
am as a person and as a man growing
while still trying to compete for a
championship every single year
um and i grew and
they allowed me to grow and we pushed
each other every single day
and like i said i fit perfectly in that
culture
because i work just as hard as anybody
else
um i i i show up to work and
uh i don't leave until i feel like i was
as great as i was
and do you always become successful out
of that are you always going to win or
you
no it doesn't happen like that but you
know you're able to sleep a little bit
better at night
when you know you you punch the clock
and
um and how am i different today
than two years ago when i entered the
finals um
a little bit more gray hair in my beard
appreciate it